the reason why the Deep State the
bureaucratic State the the neolibs the
neocons want war is to make sure we
don't lose this status so the likelihood
that we enter into a dramatically
escalated conflict is ever ever so
increasing to the point where let me
tell you how desperate the machine has
become
earlier last year or so I think it was
last year when Russia started using was
accused of using cluster bombs the U.S
the Western forces claimed that was
potentially a war crime now the the West
has become so desperate that Joe Biden
has approved the sending of cluster
bombs to Ukrainian forces something that
they had previously said could be a war
crime this is what I'm talking about the
people saying oh you can't do that
because that's evil and wrong and then a
year later being like if we lose this
we're done for so just do it anyway how
far off are we from someone saying yeah
well nukes are no longer off the table